yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your online privacy today at
expressvpn.com
[Applause]
yang
are we looking at a cabinet position
what's going on here
unofficially um in the conversations
we've had people like we'd love to have
you on the team and
work with you like things like that i
love you
what do you want to be what's your dream
what's your dream position there
i want to try and speed us up on these
technology issues
secretary of technology secretary of
technology and innovation
actually the washington post just just
put that out there today they said
here's the cabinet we recommend and they
said andrew yang i'm lobbying for that
from now on i think it's
bad for our confidence in our government
that it sucks so bad at a lot of these
things
where like if you go to uh
your bank's website or whatever you just
expect it to work
generally at a certain level um and then
so you'd be like well
why do the government have something so
one thing i'd love to invest in would be
essentially a citizen portal
where if there was something like we're
trying to get you money or trying to get
you information
um so i would love to try and help the
government deliver at
like uh on a technical level because i
think it would be enormous for our
confidence
so that would be something i would love
especially if it was tied to universal
basic income because i think that there
is a relationship where
we need to actually know who you are
know how to get you money
have to have some kind of secure
relationship with you and interface with
you if we're going to try
and you know add value
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to yang speaks
this is zach rauman i was andrew's
campaign manager and now the co-host
of this podcast with andrew today we've
got a pretty cool episode we've got a
crossover episode with the h3 podcast so
if you're following andrew on the
campaign trail we were on the h3 podcast
a few times and now we get basically a
recap
of andrew's experience on the trail and
also
a whole bunch of current events so ethan
and gila are fantastic and hilarious so
they talk about the four day work week
universal basic income andrew joining
cnn and joe biden why andrew endorsed
him
and why you should vote for him and
where we stand on a whole bunch of
issues of the day
so tune in it's hilarious it's fun and
actually a really interesting
perspective
on what's going through andrew's head
right now now that he's off the trail
tune in guys crossover episode between
yang speaks
and the h3 podcast
[Music]
with us again is andrew yang
the uh can i call you a futurist do we
accept this title
you know i used to joke ethan that
people call me a futurist but i'm
actually a presentist
because it's all going on right now
that's and
and i was contrasting myself with other
political figures who seem stuck in the
past it's like everyone's
arguing for some version of the past
so so i you know but if people call me a
futurist i mean it sounds cool it makes
me sound with it and forward thinking so
i mean i'll i'll take it
that is a good point though i mean the
ideas that
that you are speaking about only you
know
a year or two ago before kovid is
already
here now ubi was your was your
kind of main main uh
platform and once covet hit
this whole ubi discussion came for front
like all of a sudden this isn't such a
bad idea
yeah majority of americans now support
universal basic income that just came
out this week
and something like 76
of americans favor cash relief during
the pandemic which is
as you can tell a very close cousin to
universal basic income and we're getting
a ton of economic data right now
that's showing that the money we're
putting into people's hands has been
enormously positive
for the economy for those individuals
and families
uh for people's ability to continue to
spend money uh in their local
communities so it's been like a
large-scale
kind of involuntary ubi trial uh but i'm
happy to say
that it seems like now it's mainstream
wisdom and the majority of the american
people support it
i just wish it didn't have to be under
these circumstances but thank you all
because you were ahead of the curve
pre-pandemic you were like hey that's
actually a good idea
and then now we all look like geniuses
because everyone's like we should
totally freaking do this
no the timing was crazy because once
like
once the pandemic hit and everyone
started talking about cash relief
like your name started trending on
twitter because everyone was like dude
andrew has been talking about this right
before it happened the timing was
unbelievable
but what the government has done like
you said is cash relief it's not really
ubi
whereas a lot of other countries have
gone beyond
and just said you know during
during this crisis we're gonna give you
cash every month
our government has stopped short of that
they're they gave one time twelve
hundred dollars
is that enough in your opinion to to
really
help people get by well it's better than
nothing but it should have been
recurring they should have
done that sort of thing every month for
virtually everybody i just want to
say uh how happy i was to see
you and gila with your help economic
relief where you're just giving folks uh
which is an enormous difference maker i
know because we know we've been doing
something similar
now but our government should have been
doing that kind of thing from day one
for virtually all of us and the thing
that made me
there's a lot of things that made me
very angry about our approach
uh but we we're using the irs as a tool
to get people these checks
and that was the right move under the
circumstances but it still misses a ton
of people because there are a lot of
people that are not filing tax returns
that
don't make enough money in many cases
and when we were trying to
get money to people we were just doing
what ordinarily
people would do which was like been
mowing or cash appping
or paypal i mean that's how you and i
send money to each other
when we send each other money every
night which you know
what i mean but like if individuals are
trying to send money to each other
you know like you you can just do it um
so
that's what my work has been doing our
government how can our government not
use an app that like millions of us use
things like if they wanted to get money
to us they could get money
i wonder do they it almost seems like
too unofficial the government sending
money to people through like venmo or
something
do they make their own proprietary thing
like how do they do that really
within it just seems odd for the
government to send
a trillion dollars over venmo it would
have been awesome though i mean it would
have been awesome i agree
is that is that a feasibility is that a
realistic
gov i should say cash app.gov because
i'm
better friends with jack oh i did cash
app.gov
yeah so uh
it's i mean it's fun they joke about how
unofficial it seems
um but that is the kind of move that i
wish we'd made
and at this point the vast majority of
americans know we need to do a lot more
for people
i'm friends with a guy who has
essentially a dashboard to
the financial pictures of over two
million
american uh temp gig and contract
workers and so he's seeing their
financial fortunes rise and fall in real
time
and he said that like their jobs started
to evaporate
in march but a lot of them kept getting
money from the
unemployment benefits and that was like
the big lifeline for a lot of these
folks
and then he saw those benefits end in
july and then all of a sudden
stuff just starts heading down he also
said that the temp and gig
opportunities have gone down by 60
percent
large so a lot of these people don't
have jobs to seek out
um and they had money and now they're
not having money and so he's seeing it
all
uh evaporate in august so
we should be doing more of what we uh
did in april we just sent people money
we should be doing it
to virtually everyone every month to
your point too ethan because they're
doing a lot of
those sorts of things in other parts of
the world right
yeah i mean we're in this situation i
don't know how people are going to
continue to get by because like you said
the benefits basically just stopped
right where
if you're unemployed people are getting
extra 600 on top of their unemployment
and i know for a lot of people they said
this is huge uh this is helping me a lot
that's that's ran out now right and so
i i genuinely am supe and then at the
same time you have
in a lot of places the
the eviction moratorium uh expiring
and i feel like we're kind of on the
verge of
of a cliff that we're about to fall off
of i mean and and
and in the meantime the congress isn't
isn't pushing any new relief
bills or they're incapable of coming to
some kind of compromise
i mean it just seems like we're right on
the
blade's edge right now now that the fact
that my friend with this company and he
has his real-time dashboard
yeah like you can see people's way of
life deteriorating and disintegrating in
front of you
uh something like 30 of americans had
trouble meeting housing payments
last month uh and so if you have an
eviction moratorium
and uh and people's unemployment
benefits
start to dry up um you're going to see
mass evictions and
uh folks know
are going to be an unthinkable
situations pretty quickly it it really
does make me very angry
uh that our congress isn't doing the
obvious it's just showing how
dysfunctional
the government is at this point i mean
uh it's
why i ran for president and you know now
i'm shifting gears because
you know you have to do whatever you can
to solve the problem so now i shifted
gears to giving money to
folks like like you've been doing thank
you to everyone who donated yeah
um and pushing for other solutions
uh you know i'm trying to get trump out
because i think that
none of these problems are going to get
addressed meaningfully
unless we have a different set of
leaders
but that nothing i just said should stop
members of congress right now from doing
what the vast majority of americans
want to see in the form of cash relief
again you know it's like if 76
of americans are for something why is it
so hard for
our members of congress just to come
together and say let's just do what
everyone right wants and it's obvious
and economists
say it's the the right thing to do well
you know it it was just
baffling that like they just they went
on vacation
congress just bounced they went on
vacation without a deal
and i mean it's like just losing faith
in
and the entire system of our of our
government
i i was shocked that they just like
i find it so ironic that they're sitting
on a cushy salary
they've got health insurance they've got
pension they've got all these things
that that normal americans would like to
see from their jobs
and for them it's so easy to just walk
away and take a vacation while
the rest well the country is burning i
mean it's it's crazy that that's even
that they can even do that well they're
in their districts right now and
hopefully they're hearing the same thing
they're hearing everyone say yo
get back there and pass uh
this bill or recovery bill connection i
bet they're hearing that every day
all the time i hope they are certainly
like i've been
pushing in any way i can and hopefully
reason it'll be male
i just hope it doesn't require something
uh
disastrous for reason to prevail over
there
well they say about americans i think
churchill said this you can count on
america to always do the right thing
once they've exhausted every other
option
yes so right now they're going to
exhaust the people somehow survive on
nothing option
yeah they realize that doesn't yeah that
doesn't work
uh you know that the tough part is so
let's say that
i was a an awesome
uh spirited person and i ran for
congress and then i won
and then i show up it's like you show up
and there's like all this entire
giant hierarchy that's been built up and
then there are like a couple of deal
makers in your party
and you're like hey i would like to make
a deal but i don't have control over
my caucus and then we have a few lead
negotiators the other party has lead
negotiators
in this in this case it was you know
mitch mcconnell trying to rally the
republican senators and
see if they can reconcile it with nancy
pelosi's
uh uh house bill that was passed by the
democrats you go back to your district
and everyone's yelling at you and you're
like man i like i can't get this
thing done i mean part of the problem is
that you have these two sides
in congress that uh
they can go home without a deal
and then blame the other side and say
well they didn't
close the gap
okay i think i know what the deal is
you're interested in these wireless
earbuds that everyone has those little
white things that are sticking out
people's ears you're like are they for
me are they for me
but you're not sure you want to break
the bank well you know one way
you can get your hands on earbuds it
start about half the price of those
other premium wireless earbuds
they look great they work great they
sound great
they sync with your machines is the
earbuds from raycon that's r-a-y-c-o-n
the everyday e-25
ear buds it's like this like value prop
where you feel like you've outsmarted
the system because they you feel like
they're trying to sell you these
really expensive things that frankly are
really easy to lose
you could get some some that
you know they work just as well they
feel great they look great and you feel
like a little bit less of a conformist
honestly because if you wear those other
things you just feel a little bit like
they got you um well this way you can
feel like you got them
so if you are interested in getting
raycon earbuds you get 15 up your order
at buyratecon.com
yang that's by raycon.com yang for 15
off raycon wireless earbuds by
raycon.com
yang and they really are awesome i've
got them in my ears and they work
[Applause]
there's been a lot of talk i've seen of
a four-day work week that seems to be
something that that
you've been focusing a lot on lately
i'll tell you from my experience when i
was working a desk job
in israel i worked a normal office job
five days a week the whole nine to five
nine to six
and i was that whole time i was like
dude i could i could do this in four
days
easily i mean when you're sitting at a
desk you waste so much time
and i always thought that that idea was
brilliant because
it's got to do a wondrous for morale
right i mean
have you been reading studies in
literature about that
yeah the data is tremendous around a
four-day work week
and it's also common sense because work
kind of expands to fit into whatever
time you have
you know what i mean like it might give
you a bunch of stuff to do with being
like you've got five days
it's gonna take you five days right if i
say you've got this much to do with your
four days it's definitely gonna take you
four days well especially with the
promise of an extra
you know week it's motivating yeah you
know in
israel we only have one day weekend
so you know what's funny when i moved
here
i was like this is like a dream i love
the
long weekend but um i started to feel
like
god i wish i had one more day and i
started to feel guilty about that and
like i really can't get enough can i
like
wait wait tell me more so israel like uh
just as a foreigner which i'm guessing
is saturday yeah
so um sunday is the first day of the
week it's not monday
so that is wild how the like i consider
myself a fairly
worldly cosmopolitan person and i did
not know that
yeah um school is sunday through friday
and you only have saturday off they go
to school six days a week can you
imagine that hell
yeah all right i'm gonna say something
please don't judge me
um yeah i went to a prep school that had
classes on saturdays so i actually have
oh my
god you can't imagine that and so i
can't imagine it
and it was not pretty horrible
yeah but i i just read about it only
recently because you've been talking
about it and i find the whole idea so
interesting and i think
i want to read more about it and learn
what it really means because we actually
have
a business and we have maybe 20
employees so
we could decide to go that route for
everyone but
i would have to know like what exactly
it would mean
yeah you should look into it for sure
and then
maybe even run like a trial in your case
you'd run a trial but the data is very
positive where it says that
productivity uh either stays the same or
goes up
in the sense like you get the same
amount of work done
and then there are reduced stress levels
increased morale like the people use
that extra day off
uh in a way that they find restorative
and
uh productive in like a you know
personal way
and so it's me it's like upside on the
personal side
and the on the business side of the
productivity side
uh there's really no loss and in some
cases there
there are positives right so uh and
to me society-wide too america in
particular and you guys have like a very
distinct
uh job if i do say so but
you know but like america generally has
this uh
this workaholism problem or
some one person called it workism which
is probably
like maybe a better name um where
keynes projected decades ago he said
we'll be down to a 15 hour work week
because we'll be so rich
and it turns out his estimates of the
top line were right like we are as rich
as he said we were going to be
um but our work we are actually
migrating longer not shorter
because of the nature of corporate
culture and the economy where it's like
you have to be always on
and um available and the work kind of
creeps uh
and that is what's happening right now
and it's driving health problems stress
problems
relationship problems you know like that
there are uh a lot of signs already that
the american work culture is kind of
morphed into something
uh not terribly healthy and so i think a
four day work week would be a massive
improvement
for many many corporate cultures and i
got gotta say like a lot of the times
you're you're
there like you're not doing no like
you know probably like one day a week
you're just like i didn't
do today
i mean i was i probably was spending 30
hours a week on reddit
i've i've gone to pages of reddit that
men
have never even known i've been to
thousands of pages back
unknown pages have read it deep
that was my
someday i'm going to be a massive
internet creator and i'm going to spend
my time
mining like the deepest depths of the
internet in preparation
yeah exactly you know in finland
in finland the prime minister had called
for employers
to allow employees to work not only four
days but
six hours a day so they are taking it to
the next
level that's some next level stuff
i might not i might not go to that that
extreme but uh but i like where their
heads are at
right now it's not work yeah in finland
they're saying
no work but you know uh i'll tell you
what
because as business owners we're always
thinking about like
morale and you want to retain the good
and the you want to retain the talent
and make sure that they're happy and
satisfied working there so
i'll tell you what on a four-day work
week i don't think anyone's going to
leave your
company you know i mean yeah i mean
it sounds like your moral and retention
would be very very high i'm sure
your staff that are listening to this
are like suddenly nodding being like yes
yeah i don't i don't know if i can do
that for you dan and ian exactly
because we have a production schedule
what can i do i can't give you the
you know what i'm saying i mean i'm
sorry i used to work in movies
this is this is easy by comparison there
you go you don't work that's like
14 hours days regularly well and this is
uh someone because i've also run
startups and most of the startups i ran
uh we worked our asses off you know what
i mean so like
it so there isn't like uh
there isn't some something against hard
work i mean i
i love working hard uh you know that was
one of the funny things about running
for president on universal basic income
where people like what about work
and then then like depending upon my
mood i would have responded different
ways but sometimes i'd be glib and be
like i'm asian i love work
people but then you know
back off a little bit but but that that
is one of the fallacies right about the
ubi people say
oh you're just not going to work but i
feel like that's such a misunderstanding
of the human condition i mean
nobody just wants to have no purpose in
life i mean that's that's outrageous
well this is the thing that that like
you know like makes makes you laugh
is like they'll say two things
simultaneously one
work is the most important element of
human life and without it
we are lost and two no one will want to
do it if you give them a little bit of
money
right yeah that's great but those two
things
don't really come together it's like if
it's so crucial then wouldn't we do it
maybe that's a great point
i feel like also the beautiful thing
about ubi is that it goes to everyone
at any different position that they are
in life
so you could be having a crisis you
could be having a meltdown
mental thing that doesn't allow you to
work right now you know you could be
having a physical injury that you can't
work right now even if you want to so
it reaches everyone at different
places in their life you know of course
yeah like it's it's
funny that you're just thinking about
this one situation where you're healthy
and you do want to work but like
you're not going to work because you
have money because you're getting a
thousand dollars
a month yeah what if you have an ailing
loved one what if you have a
young child or something or mental
illness or
no yeah like right now we have this
incredible the dynamic
or we have a yeah or you're in a
pandemic we have this homeless problem
homelessness problem that's just kind of
crushing
la right now and if you gave each
homeless person uh
if there was that bottoms you know
social safety net
i think you would see a lot a lot less
almost probably to zero
in terms of homelessness you know now if
you had that level of resources you
could reduce homelessness very very
dramatically uh the issue it would be
the transition because some of the
people that are homeless
right now are have mental health
problems or drug addiction problems and
then
and and don't may not even have a bank
account where it's not trying to send
you the money
like what what's going on but over time
if you
knew that everyone had this money that
they were entitled to then you would
reduce homelessness pretty quickly
because then i would just look around
and be like wait a minute
like what's going on this person has got
like thousand dollars
a year in value like you know i just
need to freaking
um make sure that it's actually uh
working for them
in a way and and to the extent that
people aren't in a position where
it would work for them because of their
own volition like it'd
actually be pretty straightforward to
like help it work for them where you'd
have
like an organization being like every
homeless person i like bringing to the
shelter like we're gonna get thousands
of
so like let's go get that done i mean
it's it is funny how uh market driven
everything is in the u.s but if you give
everyone intrinsic value then all of a
sudden like
the market value starts kicking in for
people
you know the other the other kind of
nice thing i like about the four day
week is
something i i always thought about when
i was working in my
my desk job it's like
you pointed out this kind of uh
workaholic knit i think it's kind of in
israel it's the same you know in a lot
of
developed countries or around the world
i think people just
have this um overwhelming of pressure
social pressure to show how much they
care about their job by
working unreasonable hours you know it's
like
in in europe i was always blown away by
the fact that people
get like an entire month off you know
and there's august freaking everyone
disappears i mean that that to me is
is unfathomable that uh and then the
thing that that blew my mind is when you
learned that
like chinese new year even in china
these people people are getting a month
off
you don't see that are two months off
even in
no month off in america we don't have
that a little less than a month
we don't have that they travel back
their hometowns in many cases i think
it's less than a month but it's
significant yeah um though though their
work week i think is like the israeli
model of six days
oh really well so they work hard but the
thing is in israel too you don't have
that
well you get holidays but not like a
designated time off and so to me it's
like
we we as human beings need to be defined
by more than just our jobs
now i think a four-day work week would
be a massive value out of the united
states but i think that
you know you wouldn't make it uh one
size fits all for every organization
because i've been parts of some
organizations where
you probably want to have you know like
a
longer work schedule and there are
certain types of
roles and um where it makes sense but i
think as a default setting where
like the expectation is here before they
work week i think would be
an incredible improvement in large part
because what you just said ethan which
is like what is the purpose of life
yeah um is it our job or is it something
bigger uh that integrates a job includes
a job but it's not like exclusively
a job so uh
the four-day work week is something that
to me would actually make work like an
appropriate
part of our lives right um you know uh
in a way that right now we have to be
honest that it's just creeping upwards
like it's it's going like from five
plus into like that zone uh
and i'm a data guy and there are very
very clear signs that
right now it's having a damaging effect
on our
health mental health stress levels
relationships family formation
um and all of that stuff was pre
pandemic
um the post in the pandemic
uh we just have to do anything we can to
give people like a a real sense of
well-being and even folks who
are doing well quote-unquote like
relatively speaking during this time are
not exactly
like necessarily mentally
doing well you know there's just a lot
of
there's a lot of stress right now that i
think if you had
a couple of days a week or three days a
week where you were genuinely
disengaged from work it would be like
enormously helpful for so many of us
do you see yourself doing that
you know it's funny it's like it
certainly sounded like i was talking
about myself just then
um i mean for for me i'm in a similar
boat to you i think where
you know we're in a situation where
we're just trying to do positive things
and help people
like i'm very busy right now uh you know
i just spoke at the
dnc last night and then i went and
talked about my speaking and the dnc
later in the night so
uh you know we're distributing economic
relief like you we're working on this
data project where we're trying to get
people paid for their data
um i'm helping these down and ballot
candidates who are running on universal
basic income because we got to try and
make it
happen for folks so i'm campaigning for
them all the time
uh i'm campaigning for joe and come on
against trump so i'm
busier than ever and it's cool in the
sense that
like the world is on fire and i i feel
like
uh thanks to you and thanks to you some
other folks who believed in
in me like i feel like i've got
something of a fire extinguisher yeah
the world's on fire and i got a fire
extinguisher um
so like i better try and put the
fire out because you know it's like not
everyone has a fire extinguisher
it's just like you guys where you looked
up too you were like wow there's a lot
of freaking
uh need and suffering right now and like
i can help so you tried to help like i'm
in the same boat you are where
this is a time for me to like not worry
too much about
you know like you know my own uh like
balance
i mean right i think it's different for
entrepreneurs or
people who manage i mean obviously
it's it's important but for people who
don't have much of a choice in the
matter you know who are expected to do
things
[Music]
all right this episode of yank speaks is
brought to you by
expressvpn we are really passionate
about
data property data security data rights
and using a vpn particularly expressvpn
is a fantastic way to keep
your data yours how it works you
literally just download this app
on your computer on your phone press a
button and you are
basically scrambling your internet
signal it's super easy
idiots like me can do it so if you're
like me and believe your online activity
is your own business
uh secure yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com
yang today yang's got a link it's
expressvpn e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
and get three months free off this it's
a fantastic deal and it works it keeps
your stuff safe
keeps you private and it's extremely
easy and effective to use still stream
videos do whatever you want
expressvpn.com
[Applause]
[Music]
you know when you were you were running
for president
you made it super far what were you like
the fifth candidate
around there you know something like
that you don't remember the exact number
well there were different kinds of we
could go no yeah they're different
i like five let's say five top five
let's do it why not
but i mean i was yanking all the way i
still am
when you left the when you dropped out
of the presidential race
you endorsed uh joe biden
and you got a lot of for that and i
was fascinated by
you remember that i was fascinated by
the response of
how people felt betrayed by the fact
that you had endorsed joe biden
i mean what was that experience like for
you to get to have some of your
uh supporters turn on you you know i
spent a full day or so just responding
to people being like hey i understand
why you're angry
like uh because i appreciate everyone
who supported me a great great deal
uh and you know if they disagreed with
my
uh my opinion and or judgment or
decision at that time i just wanted to
try and
uh explain um and in my case too
uh joe called me and asked me for my
endorsement and i
i essentially like i was like look i
kind of want to
let this process play out uh and then i
endorsed him when
um to me he was going to be the nominee
and i was like all right like i should
do what i can to unify the party
right um and and bring us together um
so i understood i understood where
people were coming from uh
and i tried to address it and
hopefully over the past number of days
and weeks like you know more people have
um come to understand
like the situation we're in and you know
like the hopefully they're going to
support joe because to me it's joe or
trump and
um but i get it because i i was the
burner i
like bernie a lot and bernie was right
about so much
and so if someone was like you yang
like you know like you you
like uh endorsed the wrong guy i'd be
like i totally get it because
like i love bernie too and like you know
at that point he had pretty much
had no chance of of winning it was yeah
i
i am the math guy i saw the math and i
was like
this is not this is not going to happen
because like you know like
like i'll put it in you know actual
terms he needed to win michigan um
in a significant way to have a chance
and and he did not and then i was like
this shit's over
like uh you know like because he
he like won michigan uh last time so
like you saw you know like if he didn't
win it this time against joe's it was
like
you know there was no pass yeah what is
it like to get a call from joe biden
asking for your endorsement what does he
say to you
uh he calls i mean he's joe so he's like
he's like hey pal like you know
like you know like um
like how's how's the family like you
know we make small talk for a little bit
and then he's like hey could really use
your support
like like we need you
uh so and you told him let's go
that's pretty epic i will i will say
this
and this is something that um so there
are folks who are running who are
politicians
and some would take that as a pejorative
and i use it as a pejorative or like a
negative term myself sometimes like ah
politicians you know because i don't
really consider myself much of a
politician
um but there is something to be said for
folks who are effective at reaching out
and like calling in one
joe's one of those people joe's like a
bridge building relationship builder
um so it you know it's and i i have to
say like when you get that phone call
like
it does make you like more likely to
want to help the person
yeah you know you're like oh you
know because you're a human being like
the human being calls you and is like
hey you want to help but be like
you know you feel like a bit of an
being like i mean no sorry i
can't do it
it's kind of amazing from what like what
one or two years ago
from where you were to getting a call
from the vice president
asking for your support
and i'll say like you know joe called me
more than once too you know so it's not
even like this
you have his number you have a cell
number um so joe's not really the
texting type
how does it go does the call come from
like i've got joe
uh i've got uh the vice president on
this video in his case it's like i've
got the vice president
yeah in that sense some of the other
candidates you know we actually do text
like we've got each other's cell phone
numbers
um but but joe you know like joe he's
also
true trader number yeah it's like you
know yeah like the
um but yeah but i i did get it and
you're right too that that like the
ascent um
was uh you know
very dramatic and rapid again largely
thanks to people like you and hila who
understood the problems i was trying to
solve and like
the approach i was taking and had like
the vision
i mean i uh super appreciative to both
of you because you're so
human and there's something about some
of the roles that we all have
where uh and you know so you know
you remember your office job in israel
and whatnot and like you weren't being
paid to be like
ultra human at that time you were being
paid to like do whatever the heck
the role they needed you to do for uh x
days
and it took people like you getting
behind me to get me to a point where i
could make a positive difference
uh it's one reason i'm glad i'm thrilled
to be back with you all because
um yeah it's well you know i mean i just
love and appreciate both of you and feel
like
we're in a similar boat where you're
looking around the world just saying
like
is this really where we are and yeah
let's try and
move it move in a better direction are
we looking at a cabinet position what's
going on here
uh so that's there's absolutely nothing
has been
you know uh discussed in like a
hyper-official
level but unofficially um in the
conversations we've had people like we'd
love to have you on the team and
work with you like things like that i
love so we always love what do you want
to be
what's your dream what's your dream
position there
so what i've been saying uh to
folks is that i want to try and speed us
up on these technology issues
and and we could you know i think the
three of us could talk about this stuff
for hours
but our government is just so out to
launch on technology issues
and so that could be ai
that could be the selling and reselling
of our data
that could be uh media and social media
that could be
mental health issues that are attendant
with smartphone adoption on the part of
teenage girls
is that there are all of these issues
does that cabinet position even exist
it does not all right and there's that
there's a part
but there there's an advantage there
because uh
if they created a new role for me then
it's not like they'd be
blocking anyone out because it's not
like they're like 15 people being like
hey i really want to be can we
tell you innovation and technology can
we create a new cabinet
branch yes that is something
so yeah you can that's the short answer
i mean
that seems like a great a great place to
go
and perfect gang style cabinet of
technology
secretary of technology secretary of
technology and innovation
actually the washington post just just
put that out there today they said
here's the cabinet we recommend
and they said andrew yang oh like a
secretary of technology innovation that
advises all of the other
uh cabinet members that's so cool that
would be amazing
i'm lobbying for that from now on
can we do anything i actually think joe
would i think joe could garner a lot of
of uh support by by making that happen
do we have any input in making that
happen like can we do anything
well if people were to if there was a
groundswell of support being like hey
joe
like if you signal to everyone that
you're going to name andrew the
secretary of technology and innovation
it would help us vote for you
they might do it because there's no
reason not to really i mean
like again it's not like a role that
exists presently and so you know it
would make him seem forward thinking so
if
enough people and this stuff you know
it's not
uh that under the radar in the sense
again the washington post just
recommended it yeah so and when i've
spoken to people that like me
they were like well this like makes me
more excited about joe if you
bring you on this capacity yeah totally
okay
let me move on to another controversy
cnn the ultimate betrayal
so after the uh after the
after you dropped out you then you took
a um position at cnn as a
how how is it called it's like a
political
commentator yeah which by the way i love
seeing you on there
i'm just kidding i'm not i'm not
criticizing you but again that was
another thing where people are like oh
yang is working at cnn he's just
he it's a total betrayal
what do you say to that what do you say
to people who say that because a lot of
people say
cc c cnn
as uh fake news right
so yeah i know it's hard to say say cnn
so what do you say to that this is
another thing where i
i kind of sympathize in the sense that
when i was the
mavericky outsider presidential
candidate you know like a lot of the
media
organizations uh you know
kind of marginalized me at various
points and there are some people that
are very skeptical
of the news media in my case
when they asked me said hey you want to
come on and talk about the debates
um it was like a short-term offer and
deal
and to me it was like initially i was
like oh this can be something where i
keep my uh i keep my
voice out there and like hopefully try
and do something positive
particularly because the campaign ends
you know you're like thinking okay
like i'm gonna start an organization and
do these things but like it seemed like
a way to
maintain a place in the public eye um
and then
and initially i was like well i know who
knows how long this will
go for maybe i don't like it maybe they
don't like me um and then
they said to me very quickly thereafter
they were like hey like we
like you you know you want to make this
like a little bit
um more long-standing uh
so i would understand again skepticism
where people like hey
like you know screw the media um in my
case it's like a well
i used to literally like be like fight
to try and get on these networks and
be like please please like get me on now
they paid
and then now they're like having me on
and i can hopefully
both push ideas that i think are
important but the other thing
is that like i thought it was very
helpful to
normalize me to more americans because
if you look up
we had like a donald trump in the white
house in part because he was in
everyone's living rooms for
years like you're fired and like this
apprentice nonsense and then people like
oh
he's like the boss like you know and
then sort of sort of like life imitating
reality where it's like we should make
that guy president
uh so like i started out as such the
uh outsider figure that i thought that
if i could become more familiar to more
americans
where it's like oh i trust that guy you
know he's like uh
and then for some people that are like
listening to this being like i would
never trust anyone on that but you know
there are many americans who
who would trust someone more if they
were on their tv set
consistently for a period of time i love
it whenever i see you there it brings a
smile
on my face
usually it's like so depressing having
this stuff on and
um i don't know it's just it feels so
repetitive and you know what they're
gonna say but
you always have this freshness about you
and you just talk simply and it makes
sense and you get good ideas so
well thank you i agree
like yeah so it's been uh it's been an
interesting experience for me because
uh like i then never really done that
kind of media pre
my presidential run um but i'm glad that
you find my presence uplifting and then
i say something reasonably
i think you make a really good point
though because it's like if you think
cnn
is fake news and full of all this crap
why don't we get someone on there who
you know can bring a dose of uh reality
and realism to it right
so maybe because they don't do they give
you notes are they like yo here's our
talking points we gotta stick to this
like is there any kind of shadowy behind
the scenes going on
uh there has not been where i'm
concerned you know they just stick a mic
in my face and being like
andrew what did you think it just
happened and then i like say something
and then you know like no memos
i've gotten zero uh direction
and zero feedback there has never been
anything like hey yang like settle that
down or you know
like or like you know you said tulsi
gabber's name or like
like there's been zero of that it's been
always like
you're clear get lost
so um so so that that's also something
you know it's like
it's felt positive where just this week
at the
dnc or whatever i thought like aoc had
been
uh miscast frankly like and and
underutilized
and then getting the chance to say that
on cnn i was like oh this is great
like i'm really excited i can actually
point out something i think it's like a
real problem with what
um you know with the decision that was
made um
yeah so i i hopefully people
like still feel like it's me i guess
like i haven't become some definitely
i can say as a supporter i mean that
that
yeah it's it's yang on tv how's that is
that a good job they pay you all right
it's not it's not you know it's no teddy
fresh but
[Laughter]
uh but you know i mean they they do they
they do pay me every month how does it
work
do you just on call from a certain i've
always wondered how those jobs work
because they have shows they have
different like commentators and then
they bring in the people to do the
the co-commentary so are you on call a
certain hours a day and then they zap
you in how does that work
yeah i i never knew how it worked either
and i'm still not sure if this is how it
works for everyone but i'll tell you how
it works for me
so so they say is they say hey um
just be available and then i'll get a
ping
from someone typically at least 24 hours
in advance
saying like this show would like to have
you on uh to talk about
something that happened uh or something
in my wheelhouse
um and then the other thing that will
happen was they'll be like hey
there's this occasion let's call it the
the democratic national convention
where we want you on every night from
this that uh to this
so those are like the two types of do
they contacts they get
so do they pay you a retainer or do you
get paid more the more air time you get
i get a retainer so like it's the
expectation is just that
you know if they ask me to do something
that i'll be reasonably available
but if i say like hey yeah that sounds
like a good one i'm just not free that
day
then they'll be like all right it's like
wow
that's awesome so congratulations
i mean congratulations on the job i
think it's great i'm happy you're doing
it
uh usps why do we why should we burn
usps to the ground andrew
tell me what should we do about usps do
we destroy it do we dismantle it
it's not profitable
that's really the summary that it's like
in american life it doesn't make money
kill it
if you don't make money you're an infant
die you know it's like
whatever the heck is that the problem is
i mean that that's pretty much where
we've gotten to in american life now
where
like we're trying to try to turn
everything into an economic instrument
and if like
it's not uh profitable then you know it
should stop existing
uh so the post office
i will say i think that uh the the
attack on the post office stuff like i
don't think it's going to
um impact the fundamental operations of
the post office but
it is true that we we need to uh we need
to fund the post office to a higher
degree and just accept that look
it could be that mail does not make
money
uh on a you know an in on an annual
basis
uh and there are ton there are tons of
things that we do that make our post
offices less competitive anyway
it's like expecting it to make money and
then keeping it from doing things that
could make money it's just so dumb
and i don't know if israel is really
smart so you probably already do this
but like in a lot of countries
they give the post office other to
do you know it's like you can do like
basic banking services from the post
office like there are
things you can do here in the us it'd be
like well you can't do that because they
would compete with like the
check cashers or whatever like these
these private firms that do various like
you can do a lot of routine stuff in
post offices
around the world in the u.s like you
know they're real restrictions on all of
that stuff
that's true i think you can do some
stuff i can't remember right now i think
you can
cut you can convert money right stuff
like that
but i but look it's in the name it says
postal service
it's a service yeah it's it's literally
just something
that's supposed to be uh provided to us
uh and i saw something it was really
interesting where
we invested a ton in the post office
early on just to connect
communities you know like that where
literally
you had these frontier settlements right
you had to like
have some dude and a horse and like a
sack a male like getting them
their mail like they were massive
investments just to try and connect
people
and that connectivity helped lead to
trillions of dollars
in economic development over time
uh and then at some point we turned on
it we're like you got to make money like
every day
you know it's just like it's like an
investment in civilization
right and i mean if you deliver a letter
to the middle of like uh
some super remote location in
nebraska i mean there's just there's no
way that that will ever be
profitable you know but we do it to keep
our country modern and connected it's
like you said
civilization and that post office in
nebraska is a freaking hub for that town
you know like that like they
literally go in and it's one reason why
i think having different purposes for
the post office could be so important
there's another informal gathering space
that i think could be
key uh in a lot of communities and
that's the town library
and it's like how the hell the town
libraries you know won't make money
it's like you go in there they're like
freaking charging your arm and a leg for
like barring that children's book
but but one of the things that the towed
library could do
uh is to try and replace some of the
thousand plus local newspapers that have
gone out of business in the united
states because all the
content got digitized and you can't make
money off of
uh classified ads anymore because it all
went to the it went to craigslist
uh and so what happens is you get rid of
the local paper in a town which is
terrible and it's bad for democracy and
like how can you vote on what's going on
in your town if literally no one's even
covering what's going on your town it's
very important for identity
to have some kind of local publication
but in towns where the local paper
uh got eliminated what happened was the
town library often ended up
putting up like a bulletin board or like
a community board that becomes the de
facto
what is going on in my town situation so
you can imagine like a revved up
version of a town bulletin board coming
out of town libraries
um but like there are things we need to
invest in
in a lot of these communities that are
getting
decimated right now because they don't
make money
well that's i mean that's sad and i
think it's something we really need to
kind of changing how we view a lot of
things that
not everything's going to make money i
mean jeez how do we convince ourselves
that this was
this was the right way to evaluate
things i mean it's wild
i mean it's been a yeah it's been like a
massive
conditioning of american
culture what is the last 40 years what
does it say about
human beings as workers you know
if if you if you can't look at anything
and not see its value if it doesn't make
money
what does it say about human beings
well this is what i was running on
before was that i i knew that we'd been
conditioned to think that
we all needed to be economically
productive and then i said you know what
technology is going to
surpass our productivity in a lot of
these arenas
pretty quick and if we don't start
evaluating ourselves in a different way
then it's going to lead to disaster
and now we're seeing some version of it
with the pandemic
and so i think universal basic income
would very quickly disentangle
uh this confusion the the the
mixing of economic value and human value
because if you all just start getting
money
for breathing for living for existing
then
you can start to feel like okay we all
have some worth that's independent
of uh how much money i'm making at any
moment in time
and then that alone would humanize your
perspective really quickly
[Music]
[Applause]
all right this is the best ad we'll ever
read and it's for
my favorite other podcast called nerds
for humanity so
um andrew's been on this podcast a bunch
if you like yang speaks
and you love when we nerd out or get
really into the numbers
or just dive into a lot of the policy
ideas this
is the podcast for you so yang's been on
there i'm going on there which is the
biggest reason i know you're all
listening to this podcast because
screw andrew yang you want to hear from
the greatest co-host
ever zach grauman and if you do and if
you're that guy or gal listening to this
then nerds for humanity is also the
podcast for you to check out because i'm
gonna be on it
so um frankly they're they're fantastic
we are big fans we go on there as
often as we can um and you guys should
check them out because they talk about
the relevant stuff
of the day and they really get into the
weeds so it's a
it's a nerd calling in some ways but i
actually think it's kind of cool so
nerds for humanity is the name of the
podcast find it where you listen to
podcasts and you guys should check it
out
do you uh are you you i know you've
already endorsed joe biden
but is there any chance we can get you
to vote for kanye 2020 vision
well i'll tell you guys the story
because it's fun but like a mutual
friend actually connected me with kanye
cell phone and so like he was just like
hey
i wanted to connect you with kanye
because he wanted me to talk to kanye
about his run
uh because you know i ran for president
and segregate he was going to tell katie
what the presidential deal was
um so then kanye called me i missed the
call like so i played phone tag with
kanye i got a text
message um you know when i was like
you know like okay like if he wants to
connect it'd be all good and we have
some mutual friends
um uh that you know
obviously like the friend that put us in
touch was one and then i have others too
uh so uh you know kanye is a creative
genius and uh
like i'm definitely not gonna be voting
for her but
that's interesting you guys never
connected i would
i wish you guys connected i'd love to
hear that you know what i should do
right now is i should
call ya while we're out there
okay what's up
yeah i missed each other's
would you mind giving his phone number
to ian ian
our employee is a huge kanye fan
is there anything you want don't meet
your idols you know
ian is there anything you want yang to
text kanye
let's see if i have this in my
phone hang on
ask him where the album is that's it
okay
it's 307 and i'm kidding
[Laughter]
steve bannon just went to prison for the
great build the wall
i gotta say build the wall it's so funny
how it quickly went from
mexico will pay for the wall to
will pay for the wall too i'll just i'll
i'll
i'll just keep the money there's no wall
i'll just
pay for the wall to how about you pay
for the wall
how about you pay me i take the money
and then i
spend hundreds of thousand dollars of it
i mean it's it's it's incredible that um
were you blown away by that build the
wall gofundme because when that came out
it was blowing my mind
i mean it was just it was so active i
couldn't not
i saw people saying i just donated my
entire tax refund
three thousand dollars and these are not
rich people right
i'm sure they could have really used
that money especially now and
like 25 million dollars how many how
much wall does that get you like
quarter mile you know
actually so i did this exercise when i
was trying to figure out what was going
on with like the truckers and like
how much would cost to lay a highway
across the country that would just
accommodate robot trucks i was trying to
figure out
like like if if you're gonna save tens
of billions of dollars a year
like would it just pay a payoff just to
like make a
a highway that's like eight lines wide
that's just for robot trucks
and i did the math and it turns out yeah
you could
you it actually would pay for itself if
you just decided to like
like
trucks go back and forth um it costs
somewhere in like the
the low billions uh that's it you get
your money back
um over time wait when you say when you
say low billions are we talking
like like below
500 what does that mean low billions
what's what's well so
it was like one so it was and so i you
know i haven't done the math in a while
but
like i was i was trying to figure out i
was like so this
the cost savings around uh automated
trucking are tens of billions of dollars
a year
and but the main impediment is our
infrastructure because like we have you
know
big highway problems and you also have
this uh political problem that if you
had a robot truck that
uh killed someone on the the highway
that people would be like oh
like you know the robot trucks um
so then i was like okay
like like could you make it so there was
no pedestrian traffic on this highway
um by just making a new highway and i
was like how expensive is it to make a
new highway in the united states of
america so like i found out what like
the per mile was and then i
did like the thousands
so then like you'd do a similar estimate
for the wall it was where i was going
it was like how much does it cost to
make a wall over like like how long it's
like what
what kind of wall can i get for 25
million not much of a walleye
i mean i'd love to see what like and and
that the thing i mean all of its
averages because like there's certain
parts where you get a lot of wall for
that much money because like the train's
really nice and then other places you
could be i can't build a wall
here
you'd have to find like the most upper
two place in any way
um well it is fantastic i think that
they ended up just pocket i mean they
didn't really pocket the money but they
like bought a boat they were they
actually well steve bannon got charged
for
um laundering money and wire fraud
so they were like were laundering the
money they were funneling it and like
the guy who set up the foundation bought
a boat it was
awesome like there's always a boat
involved yeah there's always a boat
that's the cardinal rule isn't it
yeah it's like she's like you know i did
something
illicit if i just turn up and be like
hey you gotta come see the boat
yeah exactly it always has some name
that somehow related to some shady way i
made the money
being like steve bannon got arrested on
a boat even
oh he was on the boat when he was
arrested it wasn't
his own boat he was on it was actually a
weird twist to the story he was on some
chinese billionaires boat
and they they boarded the boat and
arrested him out on the high seas it was
like an interception
what the heck that's wild that you know
that sounds like a movie scene yeah
like chris hemsworth like comes down to
like the they should have sent chris
hemsworth to arrest him that would have
been awesome yeah i see a true
documentary coming out about this called
build the wall or something about like
the high crime documentary andrew
if you get this cabinet position which
we're all hoping for
tell me tell me what are those first
things that you think like
you're sitting down in america you're
part of the president's cabinet
what do we need to do first what is the
most pressing things we need to address
in this country america i mean
clearly it's cash relief and universal
basic income you know it's like that's
like the simple thing
um it sounds you know that's to me the
single
best thing we could do for people so
let's say if you say something
technology related then i i
you know i i'd actually choose something
related
which is what we talked about earlier
around the fact that we didn't actually
have a system set up to get people money
so we use the irs check distribution
system
um and i think it's bad for our
confidence and our government
that it sucks so bad at a lot of these
things
where like if you go to uh
your bank's website or whatever you just
expect it to work
generally at a certain level um and then
so you'd be like well
why do the government have something so
one thing i'd love to invest in would be
essentially a citizen portal
where if there was something like we're
trying to get you money
or trying to get you information or so
the lamest version of this would be a
citizen portal where
it's essentially like here are all of
these links to other government
websites that you can go to like that
would be the
the absolute worst version the best
version would be so
you know what i mean like one of those
boards where it's like here's a
freaking flurry of uh websites to go to
you but no
but but like like the good version
would be like a a slick interface where
you know like the information from let's
call it your tax returns
uh or uh from
uh the passport office or wherever the
heck like could actually be
compiled because part of the thing that
makes me angry right now is that
like you're hearing a lot of messages
from folks all the time
associated with politics which is like
trust us trust us you gotta trust us and
it's like well
like you guys don't really deliver at
the same level as like
some of the other organizations i'm used
to interacting with
um so i would love to try and help the
government deliver at
like uh on a technical level because i
think it would be enormous for our
confidence
so that would be something i would love
especially if it was tied to universal
basic income because i think that there
is a relationship where
we need to actually know who you are
know how to get you money
have to have some kind of secure
relationship with you and interface with
you if we're going to try and
you know add value don't you think the
big
problem is that all of our elected
officials and even
you know uh joe biden i mean how old is
joe
he's like 74 or something like that i
mean um i
think i think he's uh like 76 or 77 i
think
um i i don't want to misspeak i should
know that he's
he's in israel yeah okay are you looking
it up yeah okay let's see i mean
maybe when your team can yeah look it up
uh zach
he's 77 years old whoa
so don't you think that's the we need
young people who
understand this like a 70s i have no 77
year old people they're not
interested in cash app do you know what
i mean
they understand checks and that's not
their fault
it's just the way it is but i think
like we have this tendency of electing
especially lately old people to office
even donald trump
is in his 70s right he's like 72 73
years old
i mean these although he's a little 74
to be oh 74. check that one somehow he
doesn't
somehow trump i guess he's got
a young he's got a young energy right
yeah such an he's got that
energy that yeah
he does a lot i think he does a lot with
this he does like a spray tan and then
he's used to the cameras i think he just
on camera i think he comes off like that
obviously i never met him in person but
i have a feeling if you saw him in
person he would look that age
to you i do give him credit he is he has
a more youthful
spirit for whatever reason and he's on
twitter that's pretty
that's pretty epic but that being said i
don't think trump uses cash app either
and so what we need is peop is younger
people i really truly think we just need
younger people and that's one of the
reasons
not that was one of the reasons why i
liked you right and one of the reasons i
like aoc is that
we just like aoc does instagram live
every like super frequently to talk
directly with her
uh yeah she's interested she's like a
digital native
uh i think the average age of a member
of congress is 62
to your point ethan so he's not just
presidential candidates right someone
called it a gerontocracy like a rule by
the old we essentially have a
gerundocracy in the united states of
america
for a number of reasons uh one of the
main reasons
is that after you get into washington
you should try and stay there forever
and it's actually very hard to defeat
and incumbent so
you have folks like
nancy pelosi i believe is uh around
joe's age
um and she feels great but she does like
but our leaders are of another
generation
because of the way the structure this is
the the structures are set up and
it's one reason why i'm four term limits
um where
you should go to dc as a term of service
get something done and then get out and
it would help keep our legislators more
current and fresh and modern to your
point ethan because
if you go to dc you'll find it is not
exactly a tech friendly town
uh you know let you go i'll tell the
story that was gonna make you angry but
it'll be totally consistent with your
understanding of the world
so uh so i was on the trail and then
there was like this
uh asian
kid he's like you know mid-20s maybe
um and he interned at his congressional
office and then they
asked him to like uh do do something
um like answering messages
or data related like in the office and
he was
smart so he set up like a program to
like automate the process
and make it so that okay like this thing
will like happen more seamlessly and
like
you know like less labor um this will be
great
and then they yelled at him for it and
said like no we didn't want you to do
that
like like where we actually
preferred the way that like the other
person uh
could just understand and just like sit
there and like just peck at it
um all the time he was like what the
hell is going on there's like a
congressional office and so he left
he now works at facebook he like went
and worked in dc for like a summer was
like
they are freaking stuck in like the
stone age let me get the hell out of
here and then he like peaced out to
silicon valley so like that that is the
general culture in dc where you go there
and you feel like you just rewound
uh like a number of years and
if you go into some of these government
agencies it's much much worse because
some of them have been underfunded so
you have like very strange
patchwork technologies uh from past
years
uh you know like i mean i might be
exaggerating but probably not my much
like windows like 2005 or whatever like
you go in and they'll just be a bit
different government organizations so it
so that's
that's the government we have um and
like you said before it's like not
really anyone's fault
um but we need to try and speed them up
um and if i'm in position to try and
move that
in a better direction like i would take
it and do everything i could
[Music]
it sounds really we have to necessarily
we have to do that
i mean i think the i think the problem
is that
the rate of technology has cert as past
our our people it's been going so fast
that it's past them right when joe biden
was a
one in his 40s even 50s
like 25 26 7 years ago
it was uh we were 1995.
i mean i don't even know that
smartphones were popular then i don't
think no not even close
they were not not even close right so i
mean in
in his own experience in government
the technology has ran around him like
30 times
yeah it's a new it's a new world they
got rid of the office of technology
assessment in 1995 the year you just
turned
the perfect time to get rid of it yeah
they had a
they had a department that advised
members of congress on what technology
is
issues you know they should care about
and like opinions like why why did they
do that
um why did they get rid of the office of
technology assessment
uh you know like it it was like to quote
unquote save money which is like the
most asinine thing in the world because
the budget of the entire thing was like
25 million it was like a drop in
the bucket just had some smart people
around telling you it's like hey
so you know where the legislators get
their technology guidance from now
the technology companies the technology
companies are like do
absolutely nothing because everything is
perfect
and then the legislators are like yeah
that sounds about right so
they're like perfect that yeah whatever
requires the least of me
yeah so and especially if you're
donating 25 million
to my campaign that's fantastic there
was a period and it's been interesting
to see the
pendulum swing somewhat so silicon
valley could do no wrong for a long time
where dc is discriminators like oh
you're like the innovators you're the
super value creators and you're rich as
and you donate to my campaign so
let's just like
like leave you the heck alone and just
sing your praises every chance we get
uh and then that pendulum has swung
because of
uh like uh facebook screwing some things
up
and and some other problems uh so now
everyone's starting to turn on a turn
towards them and be like wait a minute
like you know is this really been like
cool that amazon
is you know like uh so
one of the things that i think amazon
did wrong there you know a bunch of
things but like
there's diapers.com where they just
lost money on diapers for a while just
like for
diapers.com to sell to them like like
amazon did that sort of thing
just because i don't i i know about that
story correct me if i'm wrong
so they basically like diapers.com was a
popular website they're selling lots
of diapers amazon lowered their price
below
that to the point where they were losing
money
just to put them out of business and
then they raised their prices back up
when they
go on not cool
so they go out of business it was like
they come to diapers.com be like hey
guys you guys are awesome how about we
take over and then diapers.com is like
no and then amazon's like oh we'll see
about this
then they lowered prices to a point
where diapers.com was like hemorrhaging
money
and then they were like okay i guess we
will sell to you now and then amazon's
like that's what i thought and then as
soon as they buy them then the prices go
back up
that's that should be is that illegal um
that is illegal yes uh or it's illegal
in the in the sense that
it's uh anti-competitive behavior it's
against anti-trust law
um so so that sort of thing has been
coming out now
is something similar with and this was
like to me the biggest nonsense was when
mark zuckerberg was asked like hey um
the people the founders of instagram are
worried that if they didn't sell to you
that you were going to
try and uh uh put them out of business
and i'll compete with them
go into destroy mode i think was that
the term i used
destroy mode and then mark was like no
i never would have done that like we all
know it's like like if instagram hadn't
sold uh
to facebook you know there would have
been a freaking like instagram clone out
like that
uh and so so that this is
officially you know it violates
antitrust law to do
certain anti-competitive things uh like
that
but the the reality is like of course
that you know if you're in that
industry like you're going to do
everything you can to try and
crush anyone who could potentially end
up taking your business
i think you have to assume
there's a lot of that going on we don't
know of with i mean any company that
gets to be that big you're looking at
the microsoft's you're looking at the
amazons you're looking at the facebooks
i mean you can't i mean
correct me if i'm wrong can you get to
be that big of a company
without antitrust
yeah it would be difficult and the thing
that most people don't realize now
and this is one reason why i think
universe basic income so vital among
others
is that some of these companies have
essentially just like left
orbit in terms of business physics like
you think okay
like i'm a company i need to like you
know be efficient and treat my workers
well and like
sell sell things at a profit there are
some companies at this point just like
i'm worth a trillion dollars i don't
even need to make money nothing matters
like
what's that you're like a cool startup
like i can buy you for 400 million
dollars and everyone's rich and i don't
even care
like they're just so unfathomably big
that like that that not like nothing
applies i think tim o'reilly called it
like super money
it's like at some point you just get
super money and then
like nothing matters and then we still
try and pretend
and what was funny is when they got
brought into congress like they pretend
to it's like oh we started in the
scrappy company they're like
they think it's like freaking at this
point they're almost like countries unto
themselves
they're just so staggeringly enormously
wealthy and they have now at this point
their stock market evaluations are
propped up
in so many ways that they can almost
do no wrong uh and uh
in that environment they're just gonna
keep sucking up more and more value
like that the thing i kept saying to
folks on the trail was like look
amazon's worth a trillion bucks
paid zero in taxes soaking up 20 billion
dollars a year in commerce closing 30
of your stores and malls and that was
pre-crisis it's like you know
these this thing's like a black hole so
it's just gonna just suck more and more
value in and we're not gonna see
anything coming out
um and you think it's like oh it's
because they're like out competing at
some point they just left orbit
and it and that the funny thing about
amazon is like there have been periods
in its past where it didn't even make
money
but at this point you look at it and
being like there was a walmart executive
who complained
to me he said how can you compete
against a company that doesn't even need
to make money
and this was walmart which is sort of
ironic because yeah walmart obviously
like crushed every
yeah like mom and pop retailer now he's
complaining about amazon
that's beautiful but yeah like i joked
with the walmart
folks it's like they were like the tanks
that came to american communities around
the country just like ran over every mom
and pop
and then they were like we did it we
conquered america and then amazon's like
a
spaceship like hovering over
them it's like
we don't need to obey the laws of
gravity anymore they're like
walmart's looking up like what do we do
and then you have our government over
here and like they're just like
you know the government doesn't
understand what is going on and just
looking up being like
yeah like amazon's a company like any
other
that's like the it's yeah they have
their own
i mean i mean if you look at what's
going on with amazon like jeff bezos is
so rich
he bought the washington post with
essentially like pocket change from his
couch
like you know like the washit post is a
very very influential publication that
happens to be like the main
news source in our nation's capital like
do you think that
you know he literally and and he has
been relatively hands off like he
has he doesn't go in and be like right
about this right about that but it is
it's telling it's that like amazon up
here jeff bezos
like you know up here and then like you
know
our nation's major media like news
source for our legislators was like down
here and he was like yeah
like sure he just like like took a
couple hundred million out of the couch
it does you know i mean it's worth at
this point hundreds of billions anyway
sorry there's no like that was
fascinating and i think it under
really carried too it's terrifying i
think the analogy of
it's like walmart came in with the tanks
and
but they weren't thinking big enough and
amazon came in with the ufo
spaceship and just zapped them i kept
thinking about
the video games you play when you're
like you keep
finishing and you replay it again with
all the upgrades yeah just
way stronger every time yeah red big
one is strong i want to wrap this story
because it's to me is interesting so the
founder one of the founders of
diapers.com was a guy named mark lore
so then amazon crushes diapers.com
absorbs them
mark laura becomes rich but he's mad at
amazon
so he comes back for revenge years later
and starts jet.com raises
i think he raised like like 500 million
a billion dollars being like we are
going to out-compete
amazon and e-commerce like he's like i
have found the way
okay and so then so he got
all of these investors to pile into
jet.com
and then jet.com is like spending uh do
you remember jed.com no
no
jet.com they had i think their color was
purple they had like chad that's some
smiling
anyway so jet.com spent hundreds of
millions trying to fight it out with
amazon
in e-commerce and then walmart buys
jet.com as a way to try and make
themselves competitive against
amazon in e-commerce
so so that's like the how it all fit
together it's like marklor came back
for revenge and then ended up like
getting absorbed by walmart in a
relatively futile attempt to try and
bring down the spaceship that's
so weird what ah that's so funny
i guess it never happened i mean walmart
failed to
to make it competitive it sounds like
yeah i don't think it's worked out
i mean like it's sure
walmart had to do something hold on
let's see if jet.com is still
yeah uh i think they paid a billion
dollars for jet.com
wow like if you look look up that were
they just thinking like look we can't
deal with another one of these
i just wanted it it was literally to try
and bring on mark lore
to be like the amazon killer because if
there was like any human
that represented like diapers
and he had a chip on his shoulder
because he was like i'm back
back you you destroyed my diapers.com
uh spaceship and now i'm back with like
jet.com and anyway
i i found uh that story really
interesting in large part because mark
was so compelling that he raised
hundreds of millions of dollars
for an e-commerce company to try and
rival amazon i thought that was like the
most amazing act of salesmanship i had
ever heard
i was like wow this guy must like be the
most convincing dude
in the world well they all they all got
they all made money it sounds like by
the
by the end of it except walmart
i think that's correct yeah yeah that's
correct but i think it really underlies
this
issue of how can we possibly govern in
the face
of such super money if our regulators
and our elected officials don't
even understand what they're looking at
like their understanding of what's going
on
at a company like amazon is so uh
terrestrial
if we're talking if they're in outer
space these guys are
you know on the ground every week i go
on amazon now i found
i find more and more creepy stuff like
at first they just had a few
like amazon basic items now it's like
every product that you look up
they already have an amazon brand that
makes it it's amazing
i just i don't know it creeps me out
ever yeah it's super weird they have
they have their own brand for literally
everything as my new as like a pen
a lighter to as big as like uh
well any clothing thing you would look
up like shopping products
everything they have it they're a
machine so what they do is they have
this marketplace
and then they have this giant data
dashboard they figure out as soon as
like something's selling at us turn
level right they're like
they go and make it just they go and
make it and so you have these horror
stories of this company being like
you know i sold on amazon and i was
happy until one day like you know the
their competitor came and i couldn't get
into the search listings and now
i am dead and like they
they're this giant uh money machine
that just comes in and like it's a
combination of like endless resources
and endless access to us and our needs
and then endless data
uh like there's no there is no real
competition
um there's something like there's
something
that has changed about capitalism
um and and the problem is that we
pretended still like the 70s and 80s
like that there is like a genuine market
between firms when you have these
uh these companies that have just
reached unprecedented
scale size resources um and it's being
facilitated by this new version of uh
of the markets where there are certain
companies that just
everyone's going to pile into because
they're
absorbing more and more of the economy
it's like you you look up and just
you know you ask anyone it's like um you
know
like like amazon apple facebook google
would be the big ones where you just
look up and being like hey
you know if you close your eyes and open
them 10 years from now like do you think
those companies will still be
kicking ass and dominating like the
answer is yes unless
uh unless the government were to change
something for one of those companies
and you're starting to see glimmers of
that
possibility because people
are starting to recognize some of the
extremes
i may be part of this conversation
moving forward too
uh oh jeff bezos just found his biggest
worst enemy
it's not mark jeff you've been looking
in the wrong place
you've been looking the wrong way okay
in closing i want to ask you
one final question you have endorsed
uh joe biden tell me why do you think
joe biden will make a better president
than donald trump
joe biden would make a better president
of donald trump on many many levels
but the things i love about joe number
one he's actually a good dude who
cares about people and like wants wants
do right by people
number two is he's really not very
ideological he's more of like a
pragmatist where he's like what are we
going to do
and as part of his pragmatism he's a
consensus seeker
he tries to figure out what the folks
around him think is the right approach
and he's not going to be someone being
like no screw you like i'm sure
like the way to go and it's not what
you're saying like he'll actually be
like well if
people uh think that this is the way to
go like i'm into it
and then the third thing is with
something i said
um at the convention which is that joe
has this quality where anything he says
becomes the new reasonable
um like he came out with a two trillion
dollar green energy proposal
that could have been straight out of the
bernier arc like uh
playbook and if one of them had said it
people would have been like oh
like you know aggressive pie in the sky
but then joe says and everyone's like
yeah that's cool
that that if
joe gets on board with something or
champions and then all of a sudden it
becomes the new main stream
and so you have to ask yourself it's
like okay maybe i just agree with john
some stuff but it's like
what what's my preferred path trying to
convince joe that this is a good idea
or trying to convince donald trump that
he should you know
like adopted a complete completely
different approach to governance
uh and yeah i mean that that to me is a
no-brainer
andrew yang future secretary of
technology and innovation
love this potentially and if that
happened i certainly have you two
and a lot of other people to thank but
the big thing right now is just for us
to help each other try and get through
this mess
and you know stay strong and healthy
ourselves because you can't help anyone
if you can't
you know like uh help yourself but then
if you do have the capacity to help
others please do lend someone a hand
because like someone in your life needs
a hand
can we count on an interview from
washington dc
a year from now yeah i mean yeah
definitely
like if i'm the secretary of
technology innovation uh then we'll have
so much to talk about and
yeah i agree i'll even end up being like
these types of being like hey send me
ideas citizens because i am now your
and andrew if there are ufos will you
tell us
but you have asked if i find out there
are ufos uh
i will tell people because we all know
they're there already okay andrew let me
ask you this
if someone's like okay andrew we're
gonna give we're gonna tell you
the ufos and the aliens and all this
crazy exists but you can't tell
anyone
do you tell us
[Laughter]
depends on who it is really i mean you
know if it's someone i can be like sorry
man
like i just had to tell people that it'd
be good people always say that but
there's no way you would actually be
able to tell us
don't you see the problem i i do see the
problem if they bring me into the circle
of
ufo trust then it's hard to run outside
of the circle
and tell ethan and hila just before you
die
just get the ball
um that done deal death bed ufo
confession
there we go all right andrew it's
been a pleasure as always i wish you
lots of luck and success i'm enjoying
following everything you're doing
fantastic
and i'm along with the yang gang all the
way so
good luck thank you both so much and
we're right there with you
thank you both for everything you do and
you know i i hope the little guy is
doing great
yeah he is he's doing awesome he is yeah
he is thank you and your kids too i mean
now
you're at home you're spending time with
the family that's fantastic i know it
was hard on you during the campaign
yeah you can understand why uh as
parents it was the hardest thing about
running um but i'm happy to say you know
yeah they remembered who daddy was
that's good and and now i'm under foot
all the time
but when i'm not you know zooming
all right andrew take care all right
thanks guys so much
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to
yangspeaks and click on notifications so
we can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you